the newest middle east violence has
escalated with palestinian militant
militants rather firing a rocket into
israel overnight israel launching its
first air strikes on gaza in months now
this follows several days of fighting
between palestinians and israeli police
at a holy site in jerusalem chris van
cleave is following the violence
happening at a very difficult time
airstrikes light up the night sky over
the gaza strip as tensions mount the
israeli military says it was targeting a
weapons manufacturing site belonging to
hamas and comes in response to a rocket
fired into southern israel no injuries
were reported
violence has been escalating since
friday clashes between palestinians and
israeli police have centered around the
al-aqsa mosque in jerusalem which is
also the site of an ancient jewish
temple it's the third most sacred site
in islam and the holiest for jews
sunday police entered the compound to
arrest palestinians barricaded inside
and blocked muslim access to allow jews
and tourists to pray
the unrest comes at a rare convergence
of the muslim holy month of ramadan
easter
and passover coupled with the first
chance for crowds to gather at the holy
site since the pandemic
the violence is prompting quote deep
concern from the state department
we as we did on friday continue to call
on
all sides to exercise restraint to avoid
provocative actions and rhetoric and
preserve the historic status quo on the
haram sharif temple mount
we also continue to urge israeli and
palestinian officials to work
cooperatively to lower tensions and
ensure the safety of everyone
clashes at the same site last may
prompted an 11-day war
killing more than 200 before ending in a
cease-fire
now a series of palestinian attacks
inside israel have killed 14 in recent
weeks prompting israeli raids in the
west bank where at least 26 palestinians
have died
now according to the state department
u.s diplomats have been in touch with
their counterparts in the region trying
to calm tensions the united nations
security council is holding a
closed-door meeting later today focused
on the spike in violence nate
chris thank you